les questions en matière et on a demandé
un sur twitter à votre avis qui va ça
qui va le plus s'en prendre plein la
tête bio soir et bien apparemment c'est
jean michel maire sur twitter où
passez-vous et sur facebook aussi qui
allait en prendre le plus ce soir on va
attendre
julien courbet jean-luc vous allez
expliquer aux téléspectateurs ce que
vous faites alors voilà vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure je prends les off qui se
passe pendant les pubs ce qui se passe
des fois avant l'émission aussi et puis
je livre au public pour que les gens
sachent exactement qui est autour de la
table c'est comme ça qu'ils viennent en
canard willy bilan à partir de surface
on vous dit que vous avez un truc qui
dépasse de votre blog est menacée sur la
même marque ces trucs comme ça d'accord
si vous voulez je peux le cacher bien
vous élimine marque à votre visite vous
avez bien fait qu'est-ce qu'on l'attend
pas
allez on y va marquer les premières
questions on y va bonjour je m'appelle
christiane j'aime beaucoup julien
courbet je trouve qu'il est très beau
très intelligent donc je voulais savoir
que fait-il dans votre équipe
c'est une excellente question chère à
christiane et je vais vous dire la
vérité
si on apprit julien courbet c'est
surtout parce qu'on avait peur de ne pas
avoir d'amis là bas c'est à peu près le
même créneau
nabila devait nous rejoindre avait même
été invité dans notre dernière émission
de juin mais hélas cyril a eu des mots
malheureux qui ont failli tout faire
foirer en plein direct
il a expliqué que s'il répondait bien
aux différents jeux de l'émission un
chroniqueur pouvez gagner un week-end
chez lui et la nabe il a paniqué et
regardez c'est très net sur les images
et je vais vous dire qui a gagné je le
rappelle un week end chez moi je vous le
dit
inquiété par sandra de cadeaux cette
année oui on l'a plus vu pendant trois
mois voilà plus sérieusement c'est vrai
que la présence de julien dans notre
équipe est surprenante car il ne
correspond pas du tout aux critères de
sélection en vigueur pour les garçons
ouais tout à fait honnête je ne savais
pas qu'ils avaient des critères de
sélection ça j'ai appris en écoutant
isabelle et enora malagré en fin de
saison dernière après les dernières 4/3
au moment où j'ai pensé que j'avais
arrêté les filmer et ben non je n'avais
pas arrêté
me donnerais pas des pellicules série
pas toujours
tous
les gros
l'appareil sont pas gardés par le roi
jean luc tout ça je sais pas il est
formidablement svelte
trop tard le mal est fait pour vous
vous aurez noté au passage que venance
notre spectateur le plus célèbre va
mieux
un nom est bien à l'émission avec des
tigres sur le pur et pendant les pubs il
est pris de convulsions et écrire
regarder
aujourd'hui
de lagord je suis pas le sommeil les
bras si on l'a placé en maison de repos
en tout cas je résume quand même pour
ceux qui voudraient rentrer dans les
clips si vous êtes un garçon vous n'avez
besoin d'aucune compétence
professionnelle confère par contre il
est essentiel que vous ayez des
pellicules du green et des nichons
bienvenue dans la famille julien marre
c'est donc julien qui aura la lourde
tâche de remplacer cyril les vendredis
puisque comme notre estomac d'ailleurs
c'est ça et ça notre maître notre mentor
notre dieu l'a rappelé la semaine
dernière mais c'est julien courbet qui
fera le vendredi de touche pas à mon
poste mais on dit ça mais c'est vrai que
je suis sûr que la formule a dû dire
finalement c'est peut-être faire un
dernier break mais je suis je suis je
suis je suis une merde merci d'être avec
toi tout cas dans un instant à cécile de
minibus
je suis une merde quelle lucidité la
semaine et je pense vraiment mais de
quoi attirer mauroy un problème et vous
non et même temps
mais oui et même votre musique qui la
supporte pas c'est quoi votre chanson
préférée en sur ma route
blake n ya qu à regarder pas cette
séquence ça va vous briser le coeur
j'adore
des dettes et les rythmes du citoyen ils
me connaissent
si vous aimez black aime ou pas elle
viendra nous voir bloquée je crois que
si la semaine prochaine ou celle d'après
a battu est bien à toi je bouge je vais
mettre un ring parce que dans son clip
en piscine à un moment et je vous met
tous les riverains vous allez aimer sa
chanson a pas mais moi je pense que
c'est pas vos goûts qui critiquent cc
vous savez que sur ma route c'est vrai
c'est quand même une superbe chanson à
texte a bien sûr le problème c'est que
personne ne connaît vraiment le texte
bah je voulais choisir votre version os
sur ma route j'ai mangé à 4 août j'ai bu
du vin de sonner mais ces bouquins
routes je me suis trompé de route
pourquoi
merci sa dette pour cette confidence
vous avez vu que mon petit il est
hargneux en ce moment si ça peut vous
rassurer c'est avec tout le monde
la semaine dernière nous recevions joan
faggianelli de bully animateur sur gulli
exactement qui avait l'air très content
d'être sur un plateau et thierry moreau
s'est fait l'air très content il n'a
rien dit mais sur son visage on a pu
sentir le bonheur et l'admiration
énervé dans le tram et cerise rien mais
qui veut tuer même jour michel et choqué
super move il leur est la raison
invoquée le cas parce qu'acheter a
choisi ses patins a vite été accueillant
tu fais un sourire c'est quelque chose
va prend exemple justement sur
jean-michel du savoir vivre
oui et en plus il se force pas c'est
sincère je vous passe quand même toute
la séquence rares cas
et je vous dire alors je connais joêl ça
l'amour de mec lui peut-être c'est oui
c'est vraiment aux libyens et aux rites
ses horizons franchement il ya une
ambiance
mais bon en revenir à thierry vous le
savez le seul truc qui me faut qu on
encore du plaisir dans cette émission
c'est quoi c'est de faire des tchèques
avec bertrand chabot exactement il a
attendu tout l'été thierry donc là il
était comme un fou en début d'émission
tu ressors où tu restes
jaurès à en tirer
regarde c'est ringard consiste à donner
quand on s'est préparé cinq ans mignon
et bien d'en faire davantage
quand tu répètes c'est qu'au moment du
tchèque bah oui tu te régales à l'époque
il
attendez le bec est au bord du précipice
vous arrivez après le cas c'est un peu
la fille de julien jeudi en fait je
devrais m'occuper de lui parce que tu
vas prendre les commandes de l'émission
le vendredi c'est vrai parce que c'est
un joli poste sony pourra compter sur la
bienveillance des chroniqueurs je sais
j'en ai prévenus présentés cet été pas
tu étais très bon jean luc la partie
j'avais d'excellents moments mais je
l'aimé les écoutez pas non mais que
jean-michel soit une petite pourriture
c'est pas une surprise mais bertrand a
lui on le sait et on commence à
connaître
je crois que vous avez créé un monde à
bord il a l'arrogance d'un justin bieber
c'est devenu une teigne
la semaine dernière il était assis à ma
place 1
devenue or et noir à rigole en plus en
même temps son rêve c'est la pire aussi
l'homme sait ils sont tous pire hélas
pas pour attraper
je suis pire mais bella il regarde elle
rigole je suis sûr qu'on a c'est la pire
encore plus nombreux ça je préfère même
pas en parler c'est dégueulasse non mais
c'est mais bon on a marqué c'est méchant
ce qu'a dit mais c'est vrai je suis plus
vieux que bertrand chamerois donc je
suis prêt à m'effacer non si si je
première phase et il faut privilégier la
jeunesse sierra leone plus vive plus
fort plus résistantes préféré
privilégier de talons non il y en a du
talent et les plus résistantes
ça se voit pas vraiment en plateau qui
est plus résistant par contre dans le
métro on sent bien cette vitalité à
c'est quand même une belle chose que la
délation mais j'irai chez toi sinon
c'est bien je sais que tu connais bien
des missions mais je voulais te faire un
petit tour du propriétaire quand même
alors déjà jean michel jean michel maire
l'année dernière c'était ça
et bien tiré le salon moi j'ai vraiment
eu moi je veux bien qu
ça s'est fini c'est fini
heureusement cette année jamais je ne
mange plus ce genre d'aliments banon il
est focus sait déjà qu sur l'émission
cyril a demandé donc maintenant jean
michel ne parle que média ne pensent qu
l'émission et pendant les pubs il
continue même les débats depuis
impressionnant là il parlait de
l'émission hommage à grégory lemarchal a
il avait une tessiture de voix de sa
carrière qui doit faire le la taille de
l'hommage
ces accords
public vous a pas
c'est qu'on serait deux minutes méfie
toi de lui de façon je pense que tu
connais le personnage puisqu'il avait
déjà critiqué ton spectacle oui c'est
vrai oui c'est vrai tout en avouant
qu'il ne l'avait pas vu un gênant pour
julien parce que toutes les péripéties
aller mieux que sa coupe à que actuelle
dont c'est vrai soit il y avait un truc
entre noirs n'essaient pas de rôle et en
plus je suis à dix ça va affecter qu'il
est pas drôle c'est ça alors qu'il n'a
jamais vu à la télé géants mais ce qu'il
advint en plus c'est la gratuité
oui alors là jean michel faisait encore
le mariole mais en fait il était assez
gêné vraiment donc à la pause suivante
il a essayé de trouver un moyen de se
racheter
mais comment faire pour complimenter un
spectacle qu'on n'a pas vu un truc à
jouer tranquille et les dialogues sont
bien
3 et que les textes sur ses serveurs et
ses tableaux
je résume quand même c'est un peu lent
citée ne l'a pas vu mais c'est un peut
réciter ce mec est un génie il a regardé
mais bon je viens je te rassure sache
qu'il n'y a rien de personnel
il fait ça avec tout le monde c'est un
toc tu t'es fait une compil juste sur la
première semaine
regarde
non mais c'est vrai qu'elle est devenue
que s'ils tombent bénin côté profs comme
ça
quand il
hazard
non c'est les psy c'est lui non non
ehpad mais non mais c'est pas lui
non mais j'étais pas à l'époque on met
trop mignon
jean luc lemoine nigeria photo
vous êtes une jeune comme ça vraiment
bien sûr canal football club ou pas
c'est une bonne ambiance c'est pas la
même ambiance julien demain vous allez
me remplacer donc ça vous gêne pas
d'être avec une équipe comme ça j'espère
qu'il va venir quand même un vendredi
assez rigolote du peu tous les deux
roues il va venir si tu réussis pas trop
lui c'est quand il fait des les
meilleures critiques quand ils voient
pas les choses
c'est sûr et pour en revenir à la
question initiale si julien est permis
nous la vraie raison c'est surtout pour
nous expliquer le principe du maillon
faible
oui parce qu'il ya du boulot la semaine
dernière nous avions fait un mini
maillon faible
je ne vais pas vous parler des règles
justes dû retourner de pancartes avec
notre équipe de flèches décrit faut
faire ont-ils écrit comme ça et après tu
fait d'arriver en temps je vais comme ça
bon faut l'aimer non non c'était comme
ça tu fais comme ça oui
des crétins quoi
c'est écrit comme ça non mais tu l'écris
comme ça du tout comme ça allait mal
tourner comme ça quand même
il redit ton truc mais non tu l'écris
comme ça et tu le tourner comme ça que
si tu es petit tu écris et tu te tournes
comme ça tu as une chance unique soit
l'envers quand tu ne montres dont il
tourne comme ça c'est non têtu tu écris
et tu fais comme ça voilà moi je fais
les trains
s'il vous plaît - cameroun canessa
jean-luc je veux juste revoir moi s'il
vous plaît la tête de mât est arrivé à
la fin qui j'ai rien compris au coach
voit soir c'est trop qu'on laisse tomber
coprolalie et moi c'est manger même flou
mais c'est super regardez regardez
c'est une catastrophe cette équipe ça
nous fait du bien de repartir notation
jojo l'intérieur qui se livrent à
regarder bonjour je m'appelle maria je
n'ai pas de question mais je voulais
juste dire que je suis très content de
retrouver thierry moreau et jean michel
maire dans ma télé il m'avait manqué
c'était de cons
oh